greetings from in front of a bookshelf
in California instead of the normal
green screen in Texas as you can
probably guess we have had to adapt the
structure of this show because of the
ongoing pandemic and what better way to
start that off than a discussion about
pandemics and literature what a time to
be alive so let's take a look at some of
the forms pandemics have taken in
fiction how have they changed as our
understanding of the science of illness
has changed in the scheme of human
history pandemics are nothing new and in
fiction they have been the inspiration
for and stuff of nightmares for just as
long pandemic Lit helps us contextualize
the real thing it mirrors our fears
about disease and societal collapse
while simultaneously showing us that
survival is possible and that rebuilding
ourselves into something new is not only
necessary but inevitable hopefully
[Music]
fundamentally a story about a pandemic
is rarely about the disease itself as a
genre pandemic literature focuses more
on sociology psychology and human
behavior in no small part because
illness is a part of life but a pandemic
is that part of life that has exploded
into disaster territory according to
susan Sonntag in her seminal work on
pandemics illness as metaphor illness is
the Nightside of life a more ownerís
citizenship everyone who is born holds
dual citizenship in the Kingdom of the
well and in the kingdom of the sick for
most of human existence people didn't
really know where disease came from
modern epidemiology was hardly a twinkle
in our scientific eye until the mid 19th
century so we gave it our best guess
magic angry gods too much phlegm in the
system and not enough yellow bile
original sin or maybe it's like an evil
stinky cloud of bad air so early
examples of pandemic literature focused
more on what people do during pandemics
with perhaps a touch of moralizing and
pontification about human nature to
quote Sonntag again feelings about evil
are projected onto a disease and the
disease so enriched with meanings is
projected onto the world the Black Death
which started in the mid for
century and wiped out anywhere from
thirty to sixty percent of Europe's
population makes its way into a lot of
medieval literature Giovanni Boccaccio's
Decameron is an elaborate anthology of
tales framed by a narrative in which ten
young people flee plague-ridden Florence
to the countryside in order to pass the
time the party takes turn telling
stories over each night during their
self-quarantine see even during the
Black Death there were long stretches of
boring during social distancing that
needed to be filled with something
obligatory Netflix joke but much in the
way that social distancing was a good
been jables story is nothing new so too
has the way early authors and thinkers
tied disease to the issues of morality
and self the Pardoner's tale from
Geoffrey Chaucer's 14th century The
Canterbury Tales conflates the
treacherous violent behavior of its
three villains attempting to kill death
in the middle of the plague to the
sinful behavior thought to bring plague
on set professor of English Byron Lee
Grigsby about Chaucer and his
contemporaries lacking any knowledge of
vector-borne diseases people of the
Middle Ages were left to conclude that
the plague was a consequence of sinful
behavior the job of the medical
theological and literary community was
to interpret the meaning of the plague
the causes of God's anger and man's sin
Edgar Allen Poe's short story the mask
of the Red Death features the indolent
greedy Prince Prospero and his entourage
is unsuccessful attempt to hide from a
plague called the Red Death by holing up
and throwing a massively extravagant
party while the poor people outside are
left to die as York University professor
Brett Zimmermann writes Prospero and his
guests employ art and the carnal
pleasures to forget death and disease
but on some deep level they recognize
the futility the vanity of their
hedonistic and aesthetic attempts to
forget disease darkness decay and death
maybe man is the real virus by Poe's
lifetime in the mid 19th century however
science began to fill in the gaps
concerning disease that had previously
been speculation germ theory
pasteurization hooray we did it but
regardless of where the disease comes
from the disease has to spread in order
to turn into a pandemic
and again as we have regrettably learned
in our current situation misinformation
can be a plague of its own in the
scarlet plague by Jack London London
writes the terror of a disease that
science couldn't keep up with with no
clear incubation period and death coming
from within 15 minutes to two hours of
the first symptoms news of its spread is
censored in the papers to avoid a panic
much like it was during an outbreak of
bubonic plague in San Francisco's
Chinatown in the early 1900s in London's
book economic greed and the herds of
people fleeing the cities in terror
further spreads the disease and is
ultimately the doom of civilization
failed government response or sometimes
even government engineered pandemics
became a popular concept in pandemic lit
during the 20th century in Stephen
King's The Stand a flu-like respiratory
virus kills over 90% of the people on
earth and the survivors have to live out
a god versus the devil chess game as bad
as Kings pandemic is it's made much
worse by incompetent and more focused
governance then came outbreak by Robin
Cook which became a best-seller in the
late 1980s and echoed the public's fear
of germ warfare and the inability of the
government to stop the plague although
the book should not be confused with the
terrible film of the same name which was
based on a nonfiction book called the
hot zone illuminate by amie kaufman and
jay kristoff elevates the inherent
horror of plague by having the infected
people trapped in close quarters on
spaceships with nowhere to escape when
the ship's AI seems to turn on its own
people in an effort to save the
uninfected the human shut it down in an
act of hubris not believing their
recommended safety procedures are
necessary this combined with the
leadership's refusal to publicly share
accurate information results in the
plague spreading through the ships and
annihilating the population but pandemic
can also be a good subject to explore
what it means to be human and what
crisis does to our humanity
French philosopher Albert Camus also
used pandemic as a vehicle to explore
the we live in a society experience in
his novel the plague in which he uses
plague as a symbol to talk about war
occupation and oppression said chemin
later referring to his experience during
the German occupation of World War two I
want to express by means of the plague
the stifling air from which we all
suffered and the atmosphere of threat
and exile in which we all live
and I am Legend by Richard Matheson a
pandemic not only wipes out most of the
world's population but the ones that are
left are now vampires the changed people
are horrifying and they're all that's
left besides the protagonist but the
book ends with the protagonists
realization that the people he'd taken
from monsters actually had a society of
their own and saw him as the horrible
monster that hunted them while they
slept did you ever think that the real
monster might be man and in station
eleven by Emily st. John Mandel a flu
wipes out most of the population and the
survivor split into cults and travelling
shakespeare companies as a pandemic
novel written in the time of social
media it focuses on how separate we
become based on petty things like our
interests and the media we consume good
thing we don't have that problem now and
of course no discussion on pandemic
literature would be complete without
talking about zombies and other
creatures that turn the sick into
monsters I am Legend style for that I
want to turn it over to dr. Z who is
something of a zombie scholar zombies
like all undead monsters can represent a
whole slew of things from the dangers of
science to Haitian slavery fears of
globalization to commentaries on
political parties they're kind of like a
catch-all for everything we're afraid of
a zombie outbreak or pandemic is even
something the CDC uses as a way to teach
people about emergency preparedness one
of the most famous literary
interpretations of a zombie plague is
Max Brooks World War Z a recorded oral
history of the survivors of a fictional
undead pandemic Brooke says that he uses
zombies as substitutes of real-world
plagues he wrote World War Z and the
Zombie Survival Guide as ways to explore
what would happen to the majority of the
population if such a pandemic occurred
saying that most people would die from
what the military calls second or third
effects for every person who dies from a
zombie bite how many people would die
from sickness or infection basically the
books are an intellectual exercise in to
how different countries respond to real
plagues
something that it looks like we should
have paid more attention to the Walking
Dead comic series is an example of how
large-scale pandemics affect communities
on a more micro level tensions arise not
only because they are trying to survive
flesh-eating monsters but because race
gender religion sex and politics still
affect day to day life spoiler alert
when it's revealed that every living
human is infected with the zombie virus
though social dynamics become even more
pronounced zombies pop up in parody
literature like Pride and Prejudice and
Zombies and even in romance novels like
in more bodies so it's not all
depressing mass destruction all the time
but it's usually not very fun thanks dr.
Z but the genre is not only about what
it does to people sometimes the disease
itself can be a character sort of in the
expanse series by James sa Corey the
proto molecule what looks initially to
be nothing more than a horrible
infectious agent might sort of also kind
of be like an alien hive mind and
ultimately it radically alters the
trajectory of human civilization and in
Orson Scott Card's ender series there is
a virus called the DES colada which is
not only integral to the reproduction of
life on its home planet it's also deadly
to humans especially if it gets off
world which is further complicated by
the discovery that it might also
actually be kind of sentient so we can't
kill it or that would be Xenocide and
Endor already did that once by accident
oopsy-daisy
boy those books got squirrely it's
important to note in these examples that
the disease does not think or act like a
human it operates on its own logic and
for its own ends the same could be said
for diseases in the real world they
aren't like an invisible enemy to fight
they aren't an antagonist to go to war
with and they don't think like a human
so it's best not to think of them as
such living through a pandemic is scary
and stressful and it would be a
disservice to not honor those feelings
but if there is hope it's in
literature's ability to show us that we
have always survived learned
adapted John Scalzi's lock-in series is
an example of books that aren't about
the experience of pandemic itself but
the world that arises after the dust has
settled how society has adapted to this
and now includes its entire class of
people who live with a disability that
resulted from the pandemic by using
androids
life after the pandemic not only exists
it creates a new normal
to again quote professor Grigsby on the
subject of plague in the Middle Ages
eventually the plague becomes so common
that people begin to deal with it as a
normal part of the human experience the
disease consequently becomes a part of
normal experience if one lives long
enough he or she will experience plague
either directly or indirectly we're
always worried and scared of the unknown
for all our scientific progress there is
always a lot more than we'd like to
admit that we don't understand but with
that comes the idea that society
survives after chaos and fiction can
tell us what to look out for and in some
cases can seem downright prophetic and
hindsight according to World War Z
author max Brooks when I was thinking of
an origin story for my fictional
pandemic I needed an authoritarian
regime with strong control over the
press smothering public awareness would
give my plague time to spread first
among the local population then into
other nations by the time the rest of
the world figured out what was going on
it would be too late sometimes art
imitates life and sometimes life
imitates art
you